hey what's up guys my name is the Jenner
and welcome to episode 94 of game
programming so we're pretty exciting
episode today because we're gonna talk
about how our chaser is actually going
to work so we have right now just so you
guys see is we have a bunch of these
dummy mobs that we made in episode 92 I
believe and we have this chaser mob that
we made last episode of certain 93 and
you can see that he's distinguished by
the red appearance here because we
actually use a quick if statement to
essentially reassign all the purple
pixels to be red when when this actually
gets rendered so we did that last
episode of course now today we're gonna
talk about actually giving this chases
on behavior so I'm actually gonna right
click on this chaser thing up here and
go close others and I will just close
every other class we have open right now
except for the chat because that's
really all we need for this episode now
let's talk about his behavior in fact
before I do that I'm actually gonna go
to the spawn level and actually gonna
get rid of these dummies at a spawning
okay now all we'll do here is why should
you spawn one tracer okay this makes
this for loop obviously redundant since
we're only doing it once we could have
done that that would have been the same
thing but the reason I am keeping this
here of course is because I'm I might
want to change that in the future I'm
gonna have to retype that for loop so
yes just to clear that up so all we're
doing right now if we launch our game is
spawning one single chaser up here and
what we want him to do is follow the
player yeah that's all we want him to do
and miss chaser entity on this this
chaser mob is he's gonna have an
extremely simple behavior okay he's not
gonna have some elaborate you know let's
let's make this guy sniff you out like a
dog and I don't know work his way around
a walls and find the closest possible
path to ignore it this is gonna be
simple
okay they're more advanced mechanics of
path finding and all those algorithms
that work that will actually use to to
essentially transport a mob from point A
to point B you know around walls and all
that stuff that'll be done in future
episodes but right now we want to start
off pretty simple because these are
these are quite these are quite stupid
mobs okay
so you know you have to it's kind of
like think of this whole AI section of
game programming that we're doing now
think of it as as almost like like the
life of a human right you start off like
a baby yeah
so like you your behaviors pretty like
you know I guess limited you can't do
really much not super intelligent or
anything and as you as you kind of grow
up you get more and more smart and you
can suddenly find your way around walls
whereas as a baby maybe if you see
something out of window you're like oh
my god I want to get to that and you
can't because it's a window in the way
and you don't actually realize that so
you know that's that's what I mean by
that Isles of smooth metaphor I just
made up on the spot
okay Ben anyway um it's like a it's like
a life kind of span okay so um that's
why we're gonna start off to start off
small also because if I dive into the
complicated stuff you guys are gonna be
like sure know do those in-depth
episodes you mentioned like half a
series ago and never actually did about
this stuff so that's why we're starting
off pretty small so um this is gonna be
simple but of course not everyone
actually knows how to do this so please
remember that for people who are going
to complain about stuff like Oh poof a
star search algorithm that's easy why
don't you do something more nor okay
chill out I hate it when people comment
being all like pretty pretty selfish and
stuff being like one of you going over
this because dude like thousands of
people watch this series okay thousands
and the thing is not everyone's gonna
understand so that's that's that's the
way the cookie crumbles
I wanted to say that I do on a daily
basis to my friends what friends anyway
so yes we're gonna make a actual method
here what should I call this we might
make a method here in update called um
to thing you a name yet I I would call
it move but move method yeah okay we'll
make one called move okay that's fine
we'll make it one make it a private
method so private void move okay and the
reason I'm doing this we're gonna move
this up here by the way the reason I'm
doing this the only reason I'm doing
this is because I I just want to keep
our code grouped over here so that we
can we don't need this update stuff we
don't need this all this crap here we
just need to focus on the move method
now the update method it's a probably
good thing to note has all of our actual
move code and move enforce references
our um our mob class here with public
would move
which really should be protected but
anyway not gonna change that now and of
course it handles our sprite directions
as well as animations for walking okay
that's worth tonight and make sure you
actually do have any move method in the
update method otherwise what I'm gonna
move anywhere so um how the movement is
gonna work is essentially X a and Y a I
believe is the way that um if we go over
here
okay this move method should really have
this move as well right over here so
let's actually cut that and yeah I'm not
sure this is a good idea
that's alright this will work that it's
just because like um all of this stuff
is really like this direction stuff it
really does have a lot to do with
actually moving but that's alright
because remember um you move actually in
in update this stuff is running this
stuff isn't running concurrently it's
actually running in you know and um
that's the right way for this I guess
it's just running in um in in order
essentially sequentially here so because
of that um this will get executed first
and everything else later that's
probably fine yeah and then at the start
we can clear our X a and y a that works
for me okay cool
so in move right just to test this out
all I'm gonna do is we're gonna actually
set X a equal to zero every frame and y
equal to zero every frame and then let's
just animate XA by setting it equal to
plus plus here so if we launch our game
right now we should say moving right and
he does okay program so that works just
testing that okay so now we can actually
focus on the code that is the the I
guess the AI
so what again our objective for chaser
is just to literally chase the player
yeah and we can do that by um a series
of if statements okay this is quite
simple you guys probably work this out
if you did this um in your heads are on
paper or whatever if you just thought
about it for a minute so what we kind of
want to do right is we want to actually
make him follow the player now if you
think about it for a minute
in order for us to make him follow the
player we need to know the players
position don't we yeah we do okay
we need to know the players position we
also need to know well that's pretty
much it that's it that's actually it all
we need to know is a player's position
in the chasers position Tess's position
we've workers waiting here players
position we do not have right now so
because of that we're actually gonna
have to make a method to get the player
because currently were unaware of all
the player is now how are we gonna do
that
okay there's multiple ways to do this of
course that's what program is all about
but the best way to do this probably at
this point is in the level class because
every entity hasn't has access to level
and what level could have is a public
void here that is a essentially get
player
okay sorry not void okay get player now
the reason why I'm kind of cautious in
doing this is because of course this
game will support multiplayer if I would
be kind of like an M and MMO cell up
here so it will have a lot of players
and because of that we will need to make
a system that deals with players and as
in like an ArrayList that deals with
players for every single player in the
game um but that's alright because all
we'll do then is we'll just simply to
change this method to this and that's it
okay and then we'll just return the list
of players so don't worry about that now
okay because I know that a lot of you
guys are worried about future proofing
this don't worry I've thought of it I've
thought about the future like every
episode so I am doing things um
generally making this series producer
sustainable as far as as far as what I
want to implement in the series go so we
won't have to write we won't have to
rewrite too much code so public player
get player and we essentially need to
return an antique that's a player so how
can we do that well first thing we need
to do is actually find the player now
the player I believe does not have his
own no he doesn't okay so he's stored an
entity right and we need to find him so
I'm just thinking in fact we should
probably future-proof this right now
that's what I'm gonna do and the reason
is it's gonna be because as this methods
gonna be um rewritten what I was gonna
do by the way is just make a full loop
so if sorry I'll just show you guys what
I was going to do
so for int I equals 0 is less than
entities dot size all you have to do
here I plus Watts of course is just say
simply that if entities get I is an
instance of player since there's any one
that we can just return entities like
yet I okay and that will work in fact
let's try let's do it that is this way
for now just because I've already
written it out and of course we need to
cosplay okay and that's pretty much it
otherwise we can just return null so in
other words there's no player which
would be weird but anyway so what we
need to do is first of all get a player
up they're going to play a player yeah
and play a player will of course equal
level dot get player and that's really
that it's really how simple this is now
if you want to be really good with
performance you could do this so it's
something like this but we will get it
every frame because I'm probably the
best way to do it so if player dot get
have any of this so the entity class not
this entity class the entity class here
should really have get X and get Y not
sure why it still doesn't I'm pretty
sure I implemented that episodes ago but
might have been a dream public void get
X return X public oh wait int public int
get Y return Y okay so we need so back
here and chase are now player get X YZ
can sit up disappeared so if player dot
get X is actually less right then or in
fact let's do this lab if our current X
location is less than play-doh to get X
then let's actually make sure we go
forward so in other words by forward I'm
in right okay pretty simple statement
here what we're saying here is that if
our current if if the current chases our
x-coordinate is less than the player's
x-coordinate didn't make then let's make
him move in the positive x-direction
because that would get him closer to the
player as far as the x-axis goes now if
we copy and paste this another further
three times we can make sure that we
handle if x is greater then play it up
get x
that case we need to actually move left
if X if Y is less than the player to get
Y then we of course need to increase our
Y and of course same thing goes for if Y
is actually greater than player don't
get why we need to actually subtract Y
to balance that out okay and that's all
we need to do so if we hit this up we'll
get a crash here with a
nullpointerexception apparently which is
a weird thing here so hang on
am i right in saying that players are
not that I'm all right in saying the
player arm gets added to entities I
think it does it would have to right
let's take a look at how we add a player
first of all so player let's see do we
have play okay we do have a player now
so player equals new player played or in
each level and oh look at that
interesting so we never actually add
player as an entity that is pretty
horrible design that I did that's not
horrible design it's just um
it's just a weird way of doing it and I
guess we do udemy here for the rendering
logic that is fine okay interesting okay
interesting so this game is made
slightly differently than I thought it
would be and I'm sorry it's just that
it's been a it's been like a year since
I started this series and of course my
conventions and my way of doing things
have evolved and this series really
hasn't well in that sense anyway so
let's go back to level and let's
implement it the way that I was going to
implement it and the way we're gonna do
this is we're actually going to make a
private list that contains player the
object player will call it players and
so I equal a new ArrayList of course
player all right and let's import
everything that I think everything is
already imported there so now we have a
list of players and so what we need to
do here is in play it or gap player we
need to actually change this to be a
list of players cases to be players and
and we can just simply let's see yeah we
can just simply return the list of
players
now one other thing we might want to do
is get a public player get player at or
something and put the index as a
parameter and it simply return players
dot get I or index in this case sorry
index and one other thing we might want
to get is public player get clients
player
yeah and I'm kind of thinking network
thing yeah that'll just basically return
players don't get zero because no matter
how many players are in the game they
are your player the player on your
client side will always be the very
first one there because of course that
will get created first as well as if it
doesn't all still get sorted so we just
need to really get the client play yeah
okay so now that that's sorted out and
we've got three methods to actually get
players will go to um I'll go to game
here just do that main class and instead
of um initializing player this way and
all this stuff we're literally just
going to hit up level dot add player
okay and because we've done this and
sorry we need to actually change this
for an ad player or in fact did we make
this universal I don't remember yeah we
did so let's put another elsif here so
else if E is an instance of player that
does not work out so if easiness is a
player then we'll go players add e
alright and what's up I'll make sure we
pass this of course okay and of course
will be we will initialize it here so we
go back to game here we can say that we
do actually add it and over here in
update we no longer need this and over
here in render we no longer need this
either
alright so player X&Y or actually look
we should really change this to get X
and get Y because they will return the
same thing and they'll actually be in
the entity class so over here in player
because of that we can now make sure
that x and y which don't even exist to
begin with where we're getting them from
we
from entity yet so they used to be
public let's make them private and what
will that do
oh sorry I'm private protected protected
okay yeah we should have no errors with
that and we don't brilliant
so back in this is a long episode isn't
it back in here yeah okay so remember to
prompter we've removed it from around it
good
so level dot render is obviously now
what the player will get rendered so we
need to duplicate this for loop and
we've got a lot of them here I know and
I'll go for I is less than players dot
size my top layer that's stuff for a mum
I should get rid of that stuff should
night this is from something else I was
working on that I forgot to do I don't
think we've covered that yeah no we
haven't I was just I was doing I was
trying to make a visual visual way to
actually show collision detection and I
needed I needed a layer of empties I'll
or a layer of sprites at least that
rendered on top of everything else so I
had to make a top layer thing don't
worry about that that's relevant top of
that later if need be even it's more of
a diagnostic tool so if I is less then
this is in remove mascara this oh yes we
good players don't sighs we'll put this
in remove as well pretty sure we've done
this Oh have we
I don't know this is the remove method I
should really I keep forgetting to
duplicate this project anyway so
fourteen eyes yeah bubble eyes that's
the pleasure size one we'll need to do
here is actually on over this is fine
so if players are get eyes removed then
we need to remove that one that's pretty
simple we also need to make sure that
we're doing it for update so copy and
paste that so for players our size we
need to make sure that we update every
player since we've removed it from the
main games update method and we need to
make sure that we render it finally now
players we want to probably render over
here we've actually got this thing up so
players get i dot render with screen if
also the parameter
so if we run our game now making sure
that we get rid of this if we run our
game now okay what we should get is this
player you see it chases us now one
thing that's not good about this is
there's like literally no delay that's a
bit weird as well oh so here's a bit
offset actually as you can see but he
moves like the same way that we do here
which is fine ah that's pretty funny
okay so if we try not away from this guy
you can see that he literally follows us
see it doesn't come to our exact
position because I think the deal is
that his coordinate is offset so what we
could do is if we really wanted to clean
this up I think the deal is if we're
going to an city is an entity no it's
chaser the way that we render him is
actually at x and y whereas if we go to
play off we can see the players run it
at X minus 16 Y minus 16 just connect
the center so if we go back into chaser
and that's actually why collision wasn't
working another thing about from the
previous episode X minus 16 y minus 16
if we launch this he should stop pretty
much exactly where we are
did you can see okay so the coolness
about this is that well he's perfect and
that's bad he's actually perfect you can
see he's actually honest exactly and
that's that's not a good thing usually
not a good thing at least because he'll
always get to us no matter what um
because he always takes him as efficient
path and but he will lose off to lose us
through walls okay so if I was true for
example go CD player sorry good game and
make sure that the player the despawned
occasional play here is as Hal
coordinates it's maybe a bit like 42 I
don't know it's probably was in a wall
no okay so yeah okay that kind of works
so I think I can yell okay I'll be able
to okay what's wrong what's wrong so
he's behind us but I believe if I wait
for meeeeee to go here yeah okay see he
can't get past the wall
obviously he's colliding with it and
this is both this
this is quite nice as well because if
you imagine like a zombie type behavior
he might not be able to get past that
like you know that might be to your game
design idea if you wanted to get past
that you'll have to work out a path
finding algorithm so he has to look at
this and say okay I can't get you using
this method what is the shortest path or
the longest path well our donor or any
path or a random path I can use to get
to your location that doesn't think that
does include walls that's where the
a-star search algorithm comes in now the
point is though we want to kind of get
away with making AI as simple as we can
okay and while of course we will cover
the a-star search algorithm in depth
well I guess normally as we do in this
game programming series which is fairly
in-depth yeah we will cover that of
course but before we do that I do want
to play around with this algorithm not
today of course because we're our twenty
minutes already but we will play around
with this method because you know as
game developers we want to kind of get
away with making things as simple as we
can okay especially if you're doing
something like a lot of day where you
don't have time okay and if you even if
you do have time this method is a hell
of a lot faster then arm this method
here which is what we're using here is a
hell of a lot faster than having to UM
actually implement a style rhythm for
each of your mobs okay without a doubt
so because of that it's it's a lot this
is much a much simpler solution so next
time I'm going to take a look at
actually kind of randomizing this making
him a bit slower to think make him a bit
slower change direction as well as
making him
just move with a bit slower or maybe
just you know not be as sure as whether
he should actually follow the player or
not or basically I guess not be as sure
as to where to play is exactly and
that'll just give him a more realistic
less robotic kind of approach to this
but anyway guys I hope you enjoyed the
steps of the game programming if you did
please hit like button 200 video at 250
s 200 likes equals one video per day and
300 likes equals two videos per day and
so yeah hit the like button if you guys
enjoy this video if you didn't please
tell me and I'll see you guys next time
good bye
you